Has this ever happened to you?
Your umbrella turns inside out during the storm.
It even happened to the President.
Now a company claims to have built the world's most indestructible umbrella.
It's called the Davek and costs as much as $350.
We use an amalgam of different materials.
Stainless steel, aircraft grade aluminum, fiberglass...
...and putting those together gives you the right balance....
...between rigidity and flexibility.
But is it really indestructible?
Our Victoria Ricano tried it out with a wind machine.
I'm putting my safety glasses on and putting it to the test.
Fire up the wind machine.
Let's see how this holds up.
The wind machine blows inside out but here's what's important.
It doesn't destroy the umbrella.
And you can pop it right back into place.
We can't say that about our cheap umbrella.
Wow, look what happened.
Now a wind machine is one thing.
What does mother nature have to say?
Inside Edition reporter Alison Hall tried it out.
Holding up so far going this way, and the real test,...
...will it go this way?
Wow!
The umbrella is holding up!
Oh my goodness!